eu ministers responsible for employment  and social affairs  are expected to adopt a recommendation  on a quality framework for traineeships  this framework seeks to ensure that  traineeships efficiently ease  education to work transition and just  increase young people's employability  if traineeships are really to facilitate  access to employment  they must offer quality learning content  and adequate working conditions  contributing to the european council at  the end of march  ministers will hold a policy debate on  the 2014 european semester exercise  the annual monitoring of economic  policies and structural reforms  ministers are also expected to agree in  principle to a proposed decision  on attributed social summit for growth  and employment  the tripleted social summit which meets  twice a year  aims at ensuring a continuous  consultation with the social partners  in implementing the eu's economic and  social policies